les réseaux de neurones artificiels sont
en partie inspiré des réseaux de
neurones biologique ce qui compose
notamment nos cerveaux de primates
sauf que bien sûr il ya des différences
notables et même énormément de
différences notables en fait les
biologistes sont très souvent en mode
vénère quand on commence à comparer l'un
et l'autre l'une des différences
importantes
a priori c'est que les neurones
biologiques sont des machines très
imparfaite
il aura arrive de dysfonctionner alors
que les neurones artificiels a priori et
au moins en principe
ils sont capables de ne jamais faillir
et ça ça donne l'impression que le
réseau de neurones artificiels
pourraient surpasser les réseaux de
neurones biologique
à moins que à moins que le
dysfonctionnement des normes biologiques
soit non pas une faiblesse mais au
contraire c'est une force
et bien en fait oui l'une des
découvertes stupéfiants de la recherche
une intelligence artificielle c'est
qu'il est souhaitable de faire
dysfonctionné de temps à autre les
neurones artificiels nous encore
introduite en 93 parquet relisant et
valais l'idée d'ajouter artificiellement
des dysfonctionnements des neurones
artificiels aussi appelé drop out a été
l'une des idées clés de l'article du jo
farrington et de ses collaborateurs qui
en 2012 allait bouleverser la recherche
dans le domaine et a annoncé l'avènement
du dip learning
mais comment est-ce possible comment est
ce possible d'ajouter des
dysfonctionnements dans l'apprentissage
de nos machines puisse leur permettre
d'être plus performante et est-ce une
règle générale alors pour commencer
non ce n'est pas une règle générale si
vous écrivez un code surtout en
cryptographie ou pour des systèmes de
sécurité ne fait pas exprès de rajouter
des bugs et surtout n'allez pas dire à
votre prof que votre copie contient des
erreurs parce que les 200 vols a dit
qu'il est souhaitable d'en créer
artificiellement nom située plutôt
d'aller voir lui-même les vidéos de ce
forum et ne pas oublier de lâcher un
pouce bleus et de s'abonner et et la
cloche aussi en général faire d erreur
dans un programme
ça empêche le programme de bien
fonctionner mais bizarrement si vous
programmez réseaux de neurones
alors il est en effet souhaitable de
créer artificiellement des bugs
aléatoire dont le fonctionnement des
neurones du réseau en fait cette
stratégie est même terriblement efficace
et aujourd'hui on va essayer de voir
pourquoi
en particulier je vais vous proposer
trois explications de ce succès de drop
out qui toutes trois ont à voir avec le
problème de la surinterprétation dont
j'ai parlé dans les épisodes 11
à 18 souvenez-vous le problème de la
surinterprétation aussi appelé over
fitting c'est qu'on ne disposent souvent
que d'un nombre restreint de données
d'entraînement
or un algorithme d'apprentissage cherche
uniquement à expliquer ces données
d'entraînement mais alors en se
concentrant uniquement sur ces données
il pourrait identifier des explications
qui n'explique que ces données et qui
pourrait très mal se généraliser à des
données autres que les données
d'entraînement et ça c'est un phénomène
qu'on observe beaucoup en pratique
surtout si le nombre de données n'est
pas beaucoup plus grand que le nombre de
paramètres de apprentissage et cette
remarque d'ailleurs elle n'est pas
restreinte aux machines landing du coup
pu faire eh bien on a vu dans l'épisode
13 que pour combattre la
surinterprétation on pouvait simplement
cherché à avoir plus de données
d'entraînement
mais supposons que l'on est accès qu'aux
données qui ont été collectés pour nous
est bien là au lieu de chercher à
collecter plus de données on pourrait
chercher à créer des données à partir de
cette que l'on a typiquement si on veut
apprendre à reconnaître des chats à
partir d'une image de chat on peut
effectuer de légère rotation des zoom
dézoom des petites modifications de la
balance des blancs ou encore effectuer
une image miroir de la photo pour ainsi
obtenir de nouvelles données dont on
peut encore raisonnablement penser qu'il
s'agit d' images de chats on parle alors
d'augmentation des données ou data
augmentation
cette technique permet ainsi d'avoir
plus de données d'entraînement et de
réduire le risque de sur interprétations
et je vous invite d'ailleurs à
l'utiliser vous même avec des textes que
vous lisez n'hésitez pas à de temps en
temps réécrire les textes que vous lisez
ou moins dans votre tête
nous en changeant les paramètres a
priori non pertinent à l'apprentissage
comme notamment les notations utiliser
ce qui est particulièrement utile pour
apprendre les mathématiques ou encore la
connotation des mots utilisés ce qui est
souvent très utile pour éviter de se
laisser persuader pour des mauvaises
raisons et bien en un sens ce drop out
peut être vu comme une automatisation de
ces techniques d'augmentation des
données en effet les bugs et nourrit
observable correspondent à apprendre des
données légèrement corrompu et le réseau
de neurones doit pouvoir fournir une
réponse
malgré cette petite corruption des
données de façon plus intrigante encore
les bugs des nouveaux intermédiaires
peuvent correspondre à des déformations
plus abstraite de l'image comme ces
histoires de rotation de balance des
blancs qu'on imagine
plus tôt alors bien sûr cette remarque
est plus intuitif qu'autre chose puisque
il est très difficile de savoir ce qui
se passe vraiment dans un réseau de
neurones que celui ci soit artificielle
ou biologique
une autre explication du succès de drop
out vient du fait que les données sont
nécessairement que des mesures et quand
cela elles sont souvent imparfaite
typiquement nos appareils de mesure des
formes légèrement les signaux qu'il
mesure on dit que les données sont
brutes et mais alors nous algorithmes
d'apprentissage qui chercheraient à
parfaitement expliquer les données
brutes rond de bonnes chances
d'apprendre la description rigoureuse du
bruit plutôt que d'apprendre des données
il risque donc de donner trop
d'importance aux aléas de la mesure
plutôt qu'à la nature du signal sous
jacent pour éviter de tomber dans le
piège de la surinterprétation du bruit
il est alors utile de supposer que les
données observées sont en fait des
perturbations des vraies données et que
ce sont ses vraies données inconnues que
l'on cherche vraiment à décrire et à
expliquer cependant on voit alors qu'il
ya nécessairement une incertitude sur
ses vraies données à décrire en effet si
les données mesurées sont égales aux
vraies données plus bruit alors on peut
retrouver les vraies données en
calculant données mesurées - bruit alors
bien sûr le bruit demeure inconnue mais
les bruits attendues vont nous permettre
d'estimer les valeurs probable des
vraies données et bien drop out peut
être vu comme une manière d'explorer
l'ensemble des valeurs possibles des
vraies données
ainsi plutôt que de chercher à expliquer
les données mesurées notre algorithme
d'apprentissage doté de drop out
cherchera à expliquer les vraies données
probable sachant les données mesurées
notez que ce raisonnement est très
proche de la notion d'ensemble
d'incertitude de l'épisode 18 dont on a
vu par ailleurs qu'elle était isomorphe
a ajouté une régularisation c'est à dire
une sorte de principe de parcimonie à
notre algorithme d'apprentissage et bien
cette isomorphisme montre ainsi
qu'étrangement 3 août n'est pas si
différent du rasoir d'occam qui dit que
les modèles plus simples sont plus
probables a priori à isomorphisme près
drop out peut donc être interprétée
comme une façon d'implémenter ce rasoir
d'occam là encore cette remarque est
intéressante pour la manière de
réfléchir de nous autres humains
quand on est confronté à certaines
données il faut préférer les
explications qui reste valide même si
ces données sont en fait erronée on dit
parfois que les explications avancées
doivent être revues
notamment par exemple à la découverte de
biais dans les données mesurées
autrement dit c'est quand même vraiment
cool de sortir des arguments de la forme
il me semble probable que x et alors on
a clairement y mais de façon intrigante
même sinon x alors y restent très
probables
ce genre d'argument est vraiment très
convaincant pour amener quelqu'un croire
y enfin il ya une dernière explication
du succès de drop out qui est de loin ma
préférée souvenez vous pour lutter
contre la surinterprétation on pouvait
soit appliqué le rasoir d'occam de
l'épisode 18 soit faire grossir toute
une forêt de modèles mutuellement
incompatibles comme dans l'épisode 17
oui parce qu'une forêt de modèle est
plus sage que n'importe quel arbre de la
forêt hashtag proverbe baïse ayant en
effet intuitivement même si un arbre se
met à faire n'importe quoi
la forêt dans son ensemble restera
robuste plus formellement prendre la
moyenne de modèles incompatibles est
vraiment l'un des piliers du bail à nice
mme on appelle ça la loi des
probabilités total comme j'en parle très
régulièrement dans mon livre
du coup plutôt qu'à prendre une fonction
calculé par réseaux de neurones
on peut imaginer qu'on dispose en fait
d'une forêt dont les arbres s'obtiennent
en éliminant aléatoirement une fraction
des neurones la prédiction de la forêt
sera alors la moyenne des prédictions
des arbres c'est à dire des prédictions
faites par le réseau lorsqu un
sous-ensemble aléatoire de neurones et
mis hors service
autrement dit au moment d'effectuer une
prédiction on prendra bien suffisamment
en compte l'avis des différents arbres
de la forêt c'est à dire le cas où
différents sous-ensembles des neurones
bugs simultanément et cerise sur le
gâteau l'apprentissage de cette forêt de
réseaux de neurones est implémenté
automatiquement par la descente de
gradient stochastique où jacques pas de
gradient stochastique est calculé pour
une donnée prise au hasard et un arbre
pris au hasard
autrement dit drop out se marient à la
perfection avec l'algorithme phare de
l'exploration d'un très grand nombre de
paramètres
guidés par des données
ainsi si je
tulle cette technique toute simple qui
est drop out qui consiste tout bêtement
à programmer la vulnérabilité passagère
des neurones artificiels est en fait une
technique redoutablement efficace pour
lutter contre la surinterprétation
puisqu'elle permet à la fois de lutter
contre le manque de données
d'apprentissage contre les erreurs des
données d'apprentissage et contre
l'apprentissage d'un modèle unique
plutôt que l'apprentissage de toute une
forêt bref les boulettes des neurones ce
sont en fait des erreurs très
intelligente
la nar fois on avait fait l'analogie
entre la descente de gradient du machine
learning et descendant une pente lorsque
j'en ai en montagne on avait vu que ça
pouvait poser problème parce que souvent
quand on descend selon la pente en
montagne va en finir au fond d'un lac
plutôt que dans la fosse des mariannes
donc dit comme ça c'est pas forcément
problématique mais bon en machine
learning ça pose problème et vous avez
été nombreux à réagir notamment une
dimension à l'idée de pourquoi pas
commencé de façon un petit peu
aléatoires pour essayer d'explorer
l'espace des paramètres avant de
commencer vraiment la descente de
gradient et aussi des idées à base de
commencer à différents points initiaux
faire plusieurs descentes de gradient
avec différents points initiaux tout ça
ce sont des techniques qui sont en fait
à implémenter très souvent dans les
algorithmes de machine learning
notamment cette seconde idée qu'on
appelle aussi le multi start de façon
équivalente le multi star ça leur
revient a commencé avec plusieurs
réseaux de neurones initiaux dont
l'initialisation et aléatoire et ensuite
à regarder ce cap à une ses différents
réseaux de neurones et on peut vouloir
du coup garder le meilleur de ses
réseaux de neurones
après avoir attrapé en tissage ou
peut-être mieux son corps ce qu'on peut
et devrait faire c'est prendre la
moyenne de ces réseaux de neurones ce
qui est vrai à une touche un peu plus
bélizienne ceci étant dit il faut
imaginer que dans les espaces de très
grandes dimensions le nombre en gros de
configuration est vraiment exponentielle
dans la dimension et du coup pour avoir
un réseau qui va tomber vers le minimum
global faut vraiment un nombre
exponentiel de réseaux de neurones dans
la dimension nous passions concert des
dimensions
1 milliards si on a un milliard de par m
eh bien il faut à peu près de puissance
un milliard de réseaux de neurones
initiaux en ordre de grandeur en tout
cas pour espérer atteindre un minimum
global autant dire que c'est un peu
complètement mort vraiment je pense que
imaginer qu'on puisse obtenir un minimum
global c'est c'est vraiment pas papa
faisable en très grande dimension
lorsque des problèmes donc complexe
comme c'est le cas en pratique pour la
plupart des problèmes de machinerie de
fullmetal alchemist demande à ce qu'il
ya une différence entre la descente de
gradient ducatel proc programmés dans
les réseaux de neurones et le fait
d'avoir une balle qui tombe qui tombe
l'apprendre qu'ils descendent la pente
en retombant en fait ce sont deux
équations très différentes puisque
lorsque la balle tombe en fait la pente
va effectuer va agir uniquement sur
l'accélération de la balle et pas sur sa
vitesse directement alors que la
descente de gradient c'est vraiment sur
la vitesse sur le déplacement et donc
une balle en fête à va gagner de
l'inertie et elle va par exemple elle
peut ainsi traverser un lac et donc
voilà un pays magique avec l'inertie
elle peut remonter et traverser le lac
et en s'inspirant soit cette idée du
d'ailleurs il ya des gens qui ont
proposé des variantes de descente de
gradient ou pareil en fait le gradient
va affecter l'accélération du
déplacement dans l'espace des paramètres
plutôt que la vitesse directement de
façon générale comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer énormément de recherches sur
les différentes variantes qu'on peut
faire autour de la descente de gradient
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire de petites
optimisations il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'idées il ya beaucoup de choses
honnêtement je vais pas impression moi
personnellement qui est un truc qui
semble vraiment émergé plus tôt que les
autres
key a pas de très très bonne théorie
assure qu'elle est la meilleure descente
de gradient possible alors peut-être que
du coup il faut un peu plus de recherche
dessus si je pense qu'il ya eu pas mal
de recherches dessus et de façon
empirique également on n'a pas j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on observe en tout cas
une méthode
dominés sur les autres en gros à présent
c'est un peu au cas par cas voilà on
fait une simulation de temps en temps ça
ça marche mais tu entends ça ça marche
mieux mais très difficile je pense qu'en
tout cas ma connaissance a priori de
savoir quelle variante de la descente de
gradient va être la plus adaptée à un
problème donné valérie on lui mentionne
l'algorithme de recuit simuler qui
inspirait de la physique et l'idée du
recuit simuler qui est très proche en
fait qu'une barre d'entre eux mêmes on
peut dire d'un cas particulier même de
des algorithmes par marco qui monte
carlo dont je parle dans mon livre et en
particulier de metropolis fasting désolé
de faire c'est un peu de name dropping
mais sont différentes idées qui sont
assez similaires et à chaque fois l'idée
de ces méthodes c'est d'avoir une
exploration des paramètres où on peut
s'autoriser des pâquis sont pas
productifs d'une certaine manière des
caïds et des papes qui nous font
remonter et temps en temps en fait on va
même avoir des phases où on va
s'autoriser pas mal de ses pas de ces
mauvais pas qu'ils me font remonter la
pente
histoire d'avoir un petit peu
d'exploration et puis ton temps on va
vraiment vouloir descendre on va rejeter
un peu c'est pas qui remonte et on veut
vraiment essayé de descendre ça
finalement c'est quelque chose que l'on
voit aussi apparaître dans la descente
de gradient stochastique ou là le côté
aléatoire possible remontée de la pente
bien du fait que la super boussole dont
on dispose donne des directions qui sont
un peu aléatoire et vont globalement
dans le bon sens mais parfois il nous
faut un peu remonté la pente et on dit
souvent informellement que ce genre de
méthodes permettent de sortir des minima
locaux alors moi personnellement je
mettrai pas mal de réserves à ça parce
que ça me paraît pas ultra convaincant
je pense que l'intuition en dimensions 1
et une dimension de assez bonne on voit
qu'on dit long sur l'évolution de sa
marche mais j'ai quand même l'impression
qu'en très grandes dimensions il se
passe beaucoup des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus subtil et beaucoup plus
sophistiqué en particulier à un truc
qu'on observe à lacets empiriquement
c'est que ces méthodes notamment de
metropolis casting on mettre beaucoup
beaucoup plus de temps à converger parce
qu'on fait en gros on fait beaucoup
beaucoup de pas inutile ou de
propositions de prades pas assez
c'est peu productive et du coup dans des
paysages qui sont vraiment très très
grand et très long à explorer d'une
certaine manière il me semble qu'à voir
c'est une boussole de descente de
gradient est déjà largement très très
bonne idée quoi qu'elles soient un peu
stochastique en plus peut-être peut
aider mais je suis je mettrai pas
vraiment un scoop et là dessus je pense
que la décence de grayan stochastique
est vraiment intéressant dans le sens où
elle est adaptée à l'album devrait être
aux populations notamment et en plus la
chance d'être adaptée à ces idées des
drop out
donc j'avais plus que c'est ça le côté
vraiment avantageux d'avoir cette
descente qui ne sont pas exactement de
gradient et qui ont un côté un peu
aléatoire et il ya une autre raison pour
laquelle le côté stochastique est
intéressant c'est que ça a empêché la
convergence vers un unique modèle et sa
force à explorer un petit peu différents
modèles et si on vend à ce moment là on
regarde les prédictions du réseau de
neurones
lorsqu'on moyenne par rapport à 10 ces
différentes variations des paramètres du
modèle là on obtient un truc un peu plus
bas et bien et je pense que c'est plutôt
ses idées qui font que l'idée de
gradient stochastique est meilleur que
des centres de gradient mais je suis pas
tout à fait convaincu par l'idée mais
peut-être que si vous avez des
références à suggérer ça pourrait
marcher sur l'intérêt serait de savoir
si en grande dimension dans des paysages
non convexe le fait d'avoir un truc qui
n'est pas vraiment une descente de
gradient permet vraiment d'avoir une
meilleure meilleurs algorithmes
d'apprentissage
moi personnellement pour l'instant je ne
suis pas convaincu mais jamais tout à
fait aussi l'étendue de mon ignorance et
si vous avez des trucs intéressants à
proposer je serai ravi de lire ça me
permet aussi de revenir sur une histoire
que j'ai l'impression d'avoir mal à
expliquer j'ai pas été très
convaincantes que l'anr fois sur le fait
que en très grande dimension à ce qu'on
a un point celle on a de très bonnes
chances de rester bloqué sur ce pont
celle surtout aussi 99 % des directions
plus exactement des espaces propres
de la matrice et ciel 6 99% de cette
direction vont vers le haut un bond vers
l'océan correspondent à une auto gratuit
donc une ligne de creux sicile 99% de
cette direction correspond en gros à des
mauvaises directions en fait une très
bonne chance de rester bloqué sur ce
point un argument qui serait plus
convaincant pour voir ça c'est imaginer
que lorsqu'on prend une direction
aléatoire c'est un correspondant à une
combinaison linéaire des différentes
directions et du coup on peut imaginer
que la contribution de chaque direction
correspondent une variable aléatoire duo
entre - rien disons que les valeurs
propres des maîtres et sociales ne sont
pas très différents les uns des autres
et le truc c'est qu'il ya beaucoup plus
de ces directions qui sont des lignes de
crête c'est à dire si les valeurs
propres d'amatrices sont plus de souvent
positives que négatives
en fait ça fait une somme dont on sait
que l'espérance est extrêmement positif
et du coup la probabilité d'avoir un
truc négative lorsqu'on une somme de
beaucoup de variables aléatoires qui ont
tendance à être plutôt positive
bah typiquement être exponentiellement
faible en le nombre de variables
victoire c'est à dire la dimension de
l'espace
bref tout ça pour dire que si 99 % des
directions correspondent à des lignes de
crête alors en grande dimension on a une
probabilité exponentiellement faibles de
réussir à trouver une direction qui
correspond à descendre de ceux de ce col
ça ça me fait dire que en très grandes
dimensions la plupart des pensées elles
sont des points sur lequel
on risque fort d'être coincé et d'où il
est très très improbable de réussir à
échapper
de façon plus générale il faut bien voir
que c'est cette analogie avec la
topographie à cette limite en cela que
la topographie que l'on connaît en tout
cas c'est une topographie de dimensions
de qui a des propriétés très différente
des espaces de très grandes dimensions
comme on a déjà parlé avec la ligier et
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
à partir de la prochaine fois on va
parler de différentes architectures de
réseaux de neurones en particulier les
données que l'on étudie avec les réseaux
de neurones ne sont pas arbitre à raison
souvent des propriétés et du coup à
cause des propriétés que l'on connaît
des données observées il peut être
adéquat d'ajuster la architecture du
réseau de neurones pour qu'elle soit un
petit peu optimisé pour les symétries
naturelles notamment des données que
l'on cherche à étudier ces centres on
parlera dans les quatre prochaines
vidéos en particulier prochaine fois on
parlait des réseaux de neurones
récurrente si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la likouala commentaire
partagé parce qu'elle vous abonner pour
ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes
neigeux et hip hop awards et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois des
fois dans la vie on aura détruit et des
fois on fait des choses qui devraient
très bien fonctionné mais qui foire sans
qu'on comprenne forcément pourquoi ça
arrive plus ou moins souvent
c'est plus ou moins graves mais de toute
façon il faut apprendre à faire avec ce
qu'on fait